peut-être un peu sombre d'accord
arrête c'est
marrant parce que c'est un lac puis une
petite rivière puis un autre lac comme un
glacier qui
bloque le ventre
ok arrête
oh cadre de pulvérisation
où elle lave les couleurs
ok continue
tu t'en es rapproché ben celui
là sur le  bon ouais je pense
que oui
c'est
ouais à trois heures maintenant tu
les regardes
hé
tellement pour cette théorie je pense que nous pourrions avoir
besoin de proposer un nouveau plan d'accord
arrête d'enregistrer
donc
c'est
juste faire attention aux animaux
très  sympa
oh
mettez une [ __ ] de gauche s'il vous plaît
un miniburger
si vous êtes plus vertical avez-vous le
bleu turquoise en dessous ouais non c'est l'
eau est un peu agitée et c'est
couvert mais nous allons je suis sûr que nous deviendrons
clair euh  tu sais le ciel bleu et ça aura
l'air beaucoup plus facile un jour ouais il y a des
ondulations sur l'eau et ça
ne me saute pas vraiment aux yeux ouais ouais
d'accord arrête d'enregistrer
dis que c'est près du pôle nord et que la
terre n'est pas verticale  c'est
quelque part là-dessus
mais je peux réparer ça
regarde ça
oh quel garçon magique
ouais
nous sommes
des fleurs qu'en est-
il seulement des nuages ​​euh
c'est
trois
deux
un